♪ (LIVELY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Hey! Yeah, it seems like there's
a party going on or something.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
It's-- it's so--
I'm cringing thinking about it.
I mean,
the whole thing was awkward.
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
So, at the end of episode three,
we meet your character. Right?
We meet Jack.
Albie thinks nothing of it.
But then in episode four,
you steal my girl.
LEO WOODALL: Sorry, bro.
It was sad as your mate, as Leo,
to watch you go through that.
Thank you.
LEO: As Jack,
it was really quite hilarious.
I think he likes ya.
Mm-hmm.
Actually, I'm pretty hot now.
-These jackets were a bad idea.
-Should we just take these off?
ADAM DIMARCO: Yeah,
let's take these jackets off.
-Let's do it. Good idea.
-(LEO CHUCKLES)
Yeah. Thank you.
I was gonna say the same thing.
That was so smooth.
So, how did you jump ship
so quickly from Portia to Lucia?
We're on vacation, right?
Anything goes.
I think he's-- At that point,
Albie's just looking for
like, the distraction.
Your character is all like,
"Let's make them jealous."
And Lucia's like,
Don't let her win.
ADAM: Haley and I--
Yeah, you guys are just like
pawns in our game.
I put on a fresh pair
of underwear for ya.
Why? Did you shit your pants?
No, they're my sexy underwear.
Oh.
I put 'em on for
special occasions, don't I?
ADAM: So, why do you think
Portia is so attracted to Jack?
What do you think draws her in
and makes her jump ship
so quickly from,
some would say,
a really great guy? (LAUGHS)
She's at a place in her life
where she's looking for
some fun.
(LAUGHS) Oh! Wow.
LEO:
She has some feelings for Albie,
but he just doesn't
make her feel alive
the way she needs to right now.
And Jack just kind of does.
I still don't understand
why Abby isn't here.
She is that mad,
and can we just not?
She's gonna get a divorce?
She can't do that.
Yes, she can. Why can't she?
You can't let her do that.
I think Albie and his father
and his grandfather,
I think they all
perceive masculinity
based on kind of
how society perceived it
at the time that
they were raised.
He almost can't understand
how it's different.
ADAM: Dominic,
he's kind of in the middle.
He was raised,
obviously, by Bert,
so he has that stuff
ingrained in him.
But Albie's also teaching him.
And I think the show
explores his needle
kind of going back and forth
between the two.
It's for your mom.
Oh! It's perfect.
She's gonna love it.
You can't just buy people off,
Dad.
I'm happy to talk to her.
She respects me.
No, she does not.
If I had to go on holiday
with one of the characters,
it would probably be my own.
He's just fun.
If you want an adventure,
stick with me.
'Cause I know how to have fun
in a sandbox,
if you know what I mean.
I-- I don't know what you mean.
I mean, I don't wanna
steal your answer, but Jack.
I'm gonna pick Jack.
Jack's a fun time.
We'd have fun.
Oh, babe.
LEO: You know what mine is.
I do. A Negroni.
-Yeah. Yeah!
-Yeah!
What's mine?
Um, uh... a piña colada?
Sure.
-Honestly, sounds amazing.
-Just anything?
Where? Where?
-It's only 'cause
you don't have one.
-Do you have one?
I would have a loose schedule.
-And a flexible schedule.
-A loose schedule?
Yeah. Yeah, I think I'm with you
on that.
You need to kind of
have an idea.
And you gotta listen
to your body if you're tired.
This is what I love about you.
You just always do--
You just know what
the right thing to do is.